14 all-star appearances five World
Series championships derek jeter hit
plenty of milestones over his 20-year
career in baseball now in retirement the
former Yankees captain tells me he'd
like to be a sports owner one day just
like his mentor Michael Jordan just not
anytime soon I don't know enough about
it to jump in the team ownership like I
said well my biggest fear in life is
being unprepared so I make sure that I'm
fully prepared before I would do
something like that so no I've got time
for that so 12 months from now we won't
see Derek Jeter team owner yeah some
money for me I think I might need to get
them from you well for more on Derek
Jeter I don't want to own a team for
more on generic Jeter's prospects were
joined by Bloomberg sports a reporter
Eboni Williams and Evan so it got us
thinking right if he were to God which
he sounds like he wants to to own a
baseball team how much money is this
gonna cost him I mean for him it won't
cost too much but as he said he needs
money it's not dark tutor made 265
million dollars on the field in his
career and if he kept every dollar of
that he still wouldn't have enough money
to buy the cheapest baseball team so so
Derek Jeter's role in an ownership group
is gonna be kind of similar to what we
saw with magic Johnson or with jay-z
who's not a former athlete also
minorities exactly a minority stake but
brings a public image to the ownership
group and something that the public can
latch onto all right I mean he at least
by his name is going to be able to get
some you know a pretty big group
together a group together of course
absolutely and in some ways when you
think about baseball and in the past 20
years Derek Derek Jeter was the face of
the sport for a while and in a way that
he came through unscathed than in a way
in a career that a lot of athletes don't
especially with the new social media and
the hyper scrutiny that we put on that
absolutely and you know Evan we so
calculated and put together the most
expensive teams out there and the
cheapest ones right so the most
expensive teams you can imagine who's on
the list right so it's the Yankees
number one of course the Dodgers and the
Boston Red Sox and they're in the
billions they're clearly out of the
range for Derek Jeter to try to buy a
great as he is alone but the most the
least valuable teams I thought were
interesting here so we have the Tampa
Bay Rays
the Kansas City Royals and also of
course the Oakland the Oakland Athletics
495 million who could he buy could he
buy one of those three alone Derek
Jeter's not gonna own a baseball team no
not alone but are those four yeah I
don't think there's a I mean there's
none for sale right now there may be
owners looking but dark shooter really
there's any any team that goes for sale
is going to be in his wheelhouse because
there's owners that are going to want to
pair with him as we said to to get
involved in an ownership group if he's
looking for a sports franchise right now
Atlanta Hawks are for sale the the nets
are poking around right that's another
area yeah but in terms of baseball he
may need to wait and he may need to wait
for a while the last baseball team
that's old i believe was the dodgers and
there was a high price tag of course
that was that was two and a half years
ago so how do baseball teams rate in
value and asset inflation versus
football teams well I mean that's about
it completely depends on what team
you're talking about obviously the
Yankees are worth more than the cheapest
football team be at the Jaguars or the
Chargers in general football teams are
worth the most because they're
meteorites are worth the most and then
on average you have very expensive
basketball teams like the lakers and the
Knicks you're very expensive baseball
teams like the Yankees like the Dodgers
like the Red Sox liquid and then there's
at the bottom end of those leagues the
teams that you're talking about the
Athletics the Royals the Rays those are
teams that are worth about 500 million
dollars so that's pretty cheap in terms
of what a major league team calls it is
ever before we go so spring training is
just around the corner what's going to
be the biggest issue this season man the
biggest issue that's a good question i
mean certainly right now looking ahead
towards the season a storyline that i'm
interested in following is Alex
Rodriguez I mean it's been a storyline
for so long but but now he comes back to
baseball comes back to the Yankees we
saw this week his hand written apology
to you what do you think of fans and
teams I think it's a step that he has to
take obviously I mean he can't come back
without apologizing that's for sure but
it will be interesting to see a what
kind of shape he's in be how much the
Yankees are willing to play him and how
much leeway they're willing to give him
and what happens with that whole
storyline is gonna be in Chelsea
certainly drama around that Evan thank
you so much ever know V Williams
Bloomberg sports reporter